I've got a great book recommendation for
you today this is one of the top
nonfiction books I've read in the last
year or two it is Thinking Fast and Slow
by the Israeli psychologist Daniel
Kahneman this book is about two
different things it is about our
intuitions and cognitive biases and it
is about what Daniel Kahneman calls
system 1 and system 2 that our minds
sort of have and for for simplicity
system 1 is our intuitive and automatic
mind and system 2 is our analytical and
slow thinking mind and I thought Pat we
would do just to give the audience an
example of some of the things that are
discussed in this book about how people
often have an intuition about
probabilities and statistics and
understanding of the world and that
intuition is not always the most
accurate okay so let's until indulge me
in a couple of different little
exercises imagine Pat that we have a bat
and a ball a baseball bat and a baseball
which together cost a dollar and ten
cents the bat costs a dollar more than
the ball how much does the ball cost I
have without thinking too deeply into it
you would say the ball costs 10 cents
right and if the ball cost 10 cents and
onat costs and the vat costs a dollar
more than the ball how much does the bat
cost yeah I got it wrong a dollar
intentions meaning the answer you gave
is wrong most people give that answer
because they see it and they're
intuitive mind says I know the answer to
that the ball cost 10 cents but the ball
actually costs 5 cents
making the bat cost a dollar 5 making
the total a dollar and 10 cents there's
a lot of science behind that and Daniel
Kahneman talks about that now Pat has
been a really good participant so far
let's go to example number two before
the show I gave Pat and melody our
intern who's here a list of seven
professions and I said I'm gonna
describe to you a 31 year old woman
named Linda and I want you to rank the
professions by which you think is most
likely Linda's profession and which you
think is least likely Linda's profession
let's put up Melody's first while I read
the problem
so we've got seven professions here
engineer math teacher bank teller
astronaut surgeon bank teller and
feminist activist and librarian and the
description of Linda I gave is Linda's a
31 year old single outspoken very bright
woman she majored in philosophy as a
student she was deeply concerned with
issues of discrimination and social
justice and also participated in
anti-nuclear demonstrations and on
screen you will see that melodie thought
that bank teller and feminist activist
was the most likely profession followed
by surgeon followed by bank teller all
the way on down to math teacher which
melodie thought would be the least
likely profession for the person I
described I gave the same little test to
Pat and we'll put Pat's answers up on
the screen and as you can see Pat
thought that the most likely profession
for Linda as described was bank teller
and feminist activists followed by
astronaut librarian math teacher
engineer bank teller and surgeon so
let's keep this up on the screen Pat and
let's focus in on this why did you
believe that it was more likely that our
imaginary friend Linda was an astronaut
than a than a math teacher well we know
she's a very intelligent young woman of
course if you're an astronaut you have
to be in that range where you're in your
30s or so because that's the correct age
and she also has a background in
philosophy which made me think that she
was more into deep thinking type roles
rather than something that's more
pragmatic like being an engineer for
example good so that so it was the
characteristics of the description yes
what made you think that it was more
likely that she was a bank teller and
feminist activist versus a bank teller
because she's involved in social
movements she majored in philosophy that
was my reasoning behind that but if you
notice the bank teller itself Falls all
the way down to number six right here is
the cognitive bias that Pat is going to
really feel dumb about but it's there's
nothing dumb this is how the mind works
if I said to you Joe is a person what's
more likely that Joe has hair or that
Joe has blonde hair that Joe has hair
because most people have hair but most
people do not have blonde hair in other
words blonde hair is a subset of hair
yes and in this case we have someone who
fits one characteristic bank teller and
someone who is a subset of bank tellers
meaning a bank teller that is also a
feminist activist mathematically how
could it be more likely that Linda is a
bank teller and feminist activist versus
just being a bank teller interesting
yeah because the only thing that stuck
out to that to me was feminist activists
and I thought that was the thing that
more correlates with her backgrounds
this is what's called the conjunction
bias that we have in our minds where if
there is a coherence to the story we
believe that we are making a more
accurate assessment by saying well bank
teller and feminist activist is more
coherent based on the description but it
is mathematically impossible because
this is likely what is more likely it is
impossible that a more narrowly defined
category is more likely than a more
broadly defined category I hope I'm not
a bad person because of them you're not
a bad person
no fascinating book okay if this is
interesting to you get the book you can
find it on my list of recommendations at
david pakman.com slash recommendations
i'm on twitter at D Pakman follow me
there